[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick wright
first things first co-host he was there
for the game last night bucks nets game
five at barclays as the series now
shifts to milwaukee for game six
and i have no idea what to expect from
the bucks well both teams going into
game six but let's
reflect on game five do you want to
start with the obvious
with uh kevin durant or do you want to
start with the milwaukee bucks game plan
nick
let's start with the good let's start
with the obvious and kevin durant do me
a favor dan at the end of this
leave 30 seconds because i have a
question for you at the very very end
let's start with durant um
it it's not only unquestionably the
finest
game of his career and i don't know what
the most impressive part is i think it's
the 48 minutes
playing 48 out of 48 the only guy
in this era that we've been able to rely
on doing that is lebron
and his body is just historically built
differently like i didn't think durant
could do that
he did it without ever resting at any
moment
and when you look at the greatest wings
of all time
dan lebron michael kobe and byrd
i am hard pressed to find a playoff game
that bird or kobe had that tops this one
bird had 37 nine and nine in a game
seven to beat the pistons in 87. he had
an unbelievable game seven against the
knicks
kobe had a 50 point game and a loss when
he was undermanned the way durant is to
uh the suns
that year in 06 when they lost in seven
i
this is one of the finest playoff games
a wing
has played in nba history and it's the
greatest game i've ever been in person
for
and i don't think any of that is
prisoner of the moment stuff you
obviously watched bird live
i i can't think of a time he was better
than this
well and i know you're talking about
wing players because i think what magic
did
in the nba finals his rookie year when
he played center absolutely
um you know i could make a case for
clyde frazier game
seven nba finals against the lakers when
he went 36
and 19 or something yeah
but what we saw with that team with no
supporting cast around him
um and it's one of those that this is
why i thought steph curry was the mvp
this year
everybody in the building knew that
steph was going to shoot but he still
led the league in scoring and he was
wonderful this year
everybody in the building last night
knew kevin durant was the option
for this team and somehow someway the
milwaukee bucks thought let's just put
one game
or one one player on him let's stay on
that for a second because
before we get to the box ridiculous game
plan on both sides of the ball just
infuriating um
what you touched on there it's
in an odd way durant's brilliance last
night
is why fans were so mad at him
for golden state and then got mad at him
all over again when they got hardened
because what is your favorite steph
curry season
maybe this one what are some of your
favorite lebron
james moments in series the 2015
finals when he was absolutely outgunned
maybe the greatest lebron game ever game
one of the 2018
finals where you want to watch john
mcclane
in die hard against 12 terrorists you
don't want to watch three john mcclanes
against two terrorists
and so there is a part as a sports fan
where you almost you don't need to see
it all the time
but you want to see the best in the
world
when they sh when the odds are totally
stacked against
him and for durant aside from
one playoff series against the grizzlies
after
russ got his knee blown or torn up by
patrick beverly
he's always had an mvp alongside him in
every playoff series he's played in
one with golden state steph wasn't there
mcclay was and so
we we never got to see this from durant
i think people wanted to see it
even if that's unfair to him like does
that make sense like this is what we
wanted to see
even if it's not sustainable for a
career you wanted to see it for maybe a
season like we got to see from steph
this year
yeah i agree it's a great point we're
talking to nick wright first things
first co-host on fox sports one
i i yelled at the tv last night nick
it's been a while since i've yelled at
the tv and i'm by myself
um and i'm just wondering
that at some point does somebody on
milwaukee's bench
tell mike budenholzer how about we run
another guy at durant how about we have
him pick up his dribble
how about we double team him if if danny
green's gonna beat us
great hardin's not gonna beat us let's
let's
you know i like our chances over here
than i do with this but you have one guy
on him
you let him go right you let him do what
he wants to do he was he was incredible
but i i i got to get the ball out of the
best players hands
nick it was offensive coaching
you'd have done better whoopi goldberg
just from
filming eddie would have done better
your old review listeners will like that
it is the the drunk teenager and i know
teenagers aren't supposed to drink but
i'm pretty sure he's a teenager i'm
pretty sure he was drunk
sitting behind me and the stands would
have done better what
listen you a couple things one is
the our statistician guy named dustin
wade i want to give him credit he he
tracked the game by hand at three this
morning so
i could have this info and i'll share it
with your audience kevin durant
was double teamed true double teamed
zero times
all game they sent a second
guy at durant so so little
he took zero jump shots with a help
defender on him
every time they sent a help defender on
him he made the pass
and it they defended it as if kyrie were
out there
and harden was full strength and it's
like ah we can't double him
yes you can you can double him and if
jeff green goes
for 47 instead of 27 then you lose
but i don't even think that was the
worst coaching job
james harden what's the old lined in a
one-legged man in an ass kicking contest
james harden was one-legged man in the
game five for playoffs man to make him
defend anybody i know how do you not
just say hey um he can't move at all
like obviously he's not a great defender
when he's healthy
i i thought in the first half honestly
and this is me giving
the bucks coaching staff too much credit
i thought they knew
that if they went at harden that they
would take
that nash would take harden out and they
were having such an easy way of it
that they were like we don't want harden
out we know we can go to that
if we need to but they never went to it
i
i it was that is the type of
franchise changing loss you're up 17
with seven minutes left in the third
quarter
and the other team's got one guy and you
just let him shoot flames out his
eyeballs and burn your house down it was
unbelievable
unbelievable and i know that if you look
at the stat line greek freak had a
a great night but it's it's not how much
you have it's when you get
that total and i he shot a fade away
with james harden
on him they didn't even double him
harden said i don't need a double waved
it away
and you know then he fumbles the ball
with the turnover
he misses a free throw like these are
these are small things and i know i'm
nitpicking but you nitpick with great
players
in these moments where you want them to
be able to show you why they're better
than everybody else
it's a two-time mvp and he shied away
from going to the hoop
because i think he was worried about
shooting free throws okay you nailed
that
a two-time mvp and one time defensive
player of the year and he guarded durant
on two shots last night
that ain't great and chuck said it your
friend charles barkley micro and charles
barkley said it after the game
and i think he's right that the the fade
away
i think is because he doesn't want to
shoot free throws and the fumble
on what should have been an easy dunk
charles said
and i'll take his word for it because
he's been in this situation not afraid
of the shooting free throws but in this
situation in the game
that he said he rushed it because he was
trying to go up too fast because he was
afraid of getting hit
that's that's not tenable and
ant and giannis i
i i almost feel like at times
the way we talk about giannis the way we
talk about some of these superstars can
be toxic i get it and i feed into that
sometimes
and i now that i like for example i see
that kawhi leonard
has like a real lower body like i you
know medical issue i feel badly about
some of my commentary from last year
so i but the other extreme of that is
i think we're almost patronizing with
some of our commentary honest
because everybody loves him he's so
likable he's
loyal he almost seems child-like likes
at times and so we don't hold him nearly
to the standard we hold anyone else in
the league
that has half of his accomplishments
which is
you gotta be better you gotta find a way
to hold on to the lead and hold on to
the ball
and he couldn't do either last night and
now the entire bucks franchises on the
brink not just the season
it's been a busy day this morning you
got stam van gundy's out scott brooks is
now
out with the wizards and you got kawhi
out game five tonight and uh
my uh chris paul is in uh covert proto i
mean this is
i i've said this the last couple of days
the healthiest team is going to win the
nba championship it feels like it's just
all of the injuries we're going to look
back on these playoffs and it'll be
it'll be the year of the injury
yeah what's up you know what's amazing i
agree with you
as far as the overall point but you know
what the healthiest team is
milwaukee and they're blowing up like
they are actually the healthiest team
and they are blowing it um but yeah i
mean
you've got if chris paul misses a game
you're going to have nine guys who made
the all-star game this year
miss a playoff game think about that
nine guys
and then at 10th and lebron who was
clearly not a hundred percent
um and speaking of the injuries thing
i are you nervous for kd
i am i i i nash
i don't think nash has done a great job
i i know i'm in the minority on that i
i didn't understand how harden can go
from out to doubtful to questionable to
46 and a half minutes i had a big
problem with that
nick that like
like i worry more about harden going 46
than i do durant going 48 which sounds
crazy considering what durant's coming
off of but
uh 46 for uh harden that's a whole lot
of minutes
it's a whole lot of minutes and it's i
just
and you know we talked about on tv this
morning and my co-host brandon marshall
said listen sometimes
it's not the coach's choice if a guy is
you know a
hardened stature says i'm going to play
he's going to play
and i buy that to a degree but it is
certainly the coach's choice how much he
plays
and i and i'm guessing when james horn's
like coach
i'm going to give it a go he didn't
think that meant he was going to sit for
94 seconds
like i so i now i understand i don't
want to play mike james either if i'm
steve nash i think their best point
guard option is steve nash
and you might say well nick then the
bucks would just you know torture nash
on defense no they wouldn't
they didn't torture her not even nash
could have suited it up stood in the
corner too
maybe knocked down some threes it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable
can i ask you my question yes you can um
assuming it happens uh do you want to go
to game seven
let's do it dan come on you and i've
never hung out you can't be that far of
a drive
i don't i don't get any comp tickets
like you i'm not fancy
i don't sit in press area i sit amongst
the people
good not amazing seats now if you want
to go and you want to pay for them we
can upgrade them that's fine
but otherwise let's go to a game seven
man come on make the drive
do it dan you don't have to commit right
now but promise me you'll think about it
saturday night my family's out of town
i'm all alone
i took my wife and daughters to the game
yesterday they all leave me tomorrow
i'm gonna be sad by myself unless you
come let's go let's do it dan
wait so game seven is if it exists it's
saturday night
i am visiting my son
and his wife oh my god oh my god i don't
even know that you have a son
i i do i have one and uh
i he's uh in charleston south carolina
i'm gonna go visit him
wow right now fritzy booking your plane
ticket just so you as the alibi checks
out
no wow you rather you'd rather
yes and it's worth buying a fake ticket
than to go
i think with you to the game because if
you had better seats then i could
i you know what how about mclovin
mclovin lives in brooklyn
he lives right by barclays 10 minute
train ride
where you know i'd like to sit up closer
but i could settle
well listen i don't buy terrible seats i
was like
12th row behind the nets bench last
night what i'm saying is
i feel like you know dan patrick's motto
has been if your feet ain't on the wood
it's no good
and i don't got dan patrick money i got
nick wright money okay but are you
just saying you don't want to have
mclovin go with you just say that nick
i'm i what i'm saying is i'm visiting my
son in charleston south carolina
mcglovin i'm sorry
and that that is fair that's a great
excuse i'm going to use that one day
you should i'll take your ticket if
you're going to be in charleston with
dan
you know what nick the next round then
will go to a brooklyn game how about
that
oh okay locked if they make it which but
let me
let me do do you think they can win a
game without durant doing this
like that's the other thing it's like
does durant have to do this again
i think he's gonna have to he's gonna
have to come close to it
now hardin can't be as bad as he was um
but then danny green is probably not
going to knock down
oh yeah jeff same thing um
he's not going to be shooting the way he
did probably maybe joe harris comes
alive
you know pick up the white courtesy
phone
do you think when joe harris goes in the
locker room and he takes off his jersey
he's actually kyle korver
and it's like hey look the greatest
three-point shooter in nba history until
the playoffs start
and then it's tied to the backboard wow
like i said oh was that unfair yeah
am i am i still bitter that korver cost
lebron that's
game three against stranton 2017 maybe a
little better
a little better i'll see you in
charleston this weekend absolutely our
sons we're all gonna force them playing
golf it'll be great that's
nick wright first things first co-host
fox sports one